so yesterday January 4th officers from
the Enix City Police Department were
summoned to 4923 North Albert Drive in
reference to a welfare check
concerned families and friends had
contacted police earlier after not
hearing from the the people there
officers entered the Residence at
approximately 4 pm
and discovered three adults and five
miners deceased inside the home and each
appeared to have sustained gunshot
wounds
while this intense investigation is
ongoing investigators currently believe
there are no suspects outstanding
evidence suggests that the suspect took
his own life after killing seven others
in the home
the suspect is 42 year old Michael hate
the two other adults in the home were
Hate's wife Tasha hate
40 years of age and Tasha's mother
78 year old Gail Earl
the miners were Hate's children
a 17 year old female
12 year old female
seven-year-old female seven-year-old
male and a four-year-old male
now welfare checks are common
and
um
someone with whom Tasha had an
appointment just yesterday morning
called and reported that she had missed
the appointment and requested a law
enforcement conduct a welfare check
a few hours after that welfare check
call came in and and Tasha was not
located
a message person's report was requested
and and
was received by Cedar City Police
Department due to Michael's office
location in Cedar City
once determined Michael's home address
was in Enoch City the missing person's
report was passed to Enix City officers
at which point the welfare check to
locate Tasha
became an effort to find the entire
family
a little bit of ancillary information is
is known by court documents that there
was a divorce petition that was filed
and that was made part of the
information given to dispatch
um
crime scene technicians from the Iron
County Sheriff's Department
Cedar City police department and any
City any City Police Department worked
throughout the night in fact um
some of them are still on duty
um
to piece together the events
and to continue to guess investigate the
details of what happened
in the early hours of this morning the
decedents were transported away from the
home
and as part of the investigation we'll
have our autopsies conducted by the
state medical examiner's office in
Northern Utah
now um
other family members are have been
contacted of course before we set any
press releases out
and they are well aware of the situation
and having conversations with
investigators as we speak
now we're going to have the mayor talk
to you a little bit about the community
and give you what's happening right now
and then at the permission of the Iron
County School District
Tim Marriott will be talking to you
about the resources that that have been
provided there so mayor Chestnut
good morning thank you
um I am Jeffrey Chestnut I'm the mayor
here in New York City
um
it's not too often something like this
hits very close to home uh in fact the
hates were my neighbors the youngest
children played in my yard with my sons
Enix city is a very
close community
just a few weeks ago I was mentioning to
my wife
as I looked at a Zillow app that less
than one percent of the homes in Enoch
city were for sale
no one wants to leave here
the neighbors are good the people are
wonderful
and the efforts that we make on one
another's behalf
is like family
I've seen reports that put Enoch as a
rural community
but you should understand that Enoch is
uh a home of lots of young professionals
and their families
our neighborhood alone
one cul-de-sac
I think at last counts about two years
ago had I think 55 kids in it
so this is a a tremendous blow to many
many families
who
have spent many many nights with these
individuals who are now gone
is unfortunate what we're dealing with
but we appreciate both the respect that
the media has shown to this point
seeing some of the reporting I know that
some information has been available
through public documents and I
appreciate the respect that the media
has shown to the family and the
community to this point
I also am very appreciative
of the resources that have been made
available to our community we've had
calls from Governor Spencer Cox
expressing condolences I spoke with him
last night in the command center and as
recently as this morning we received
calls and requests or an offer for
assistance
from the National Security Council
uh wanting to make sure that if we
needed resources for our community given
the scale of this incident that they
would be a meat available
so we here in Enoch a little town of
about 7 500 are very grateful to the
greater World At Large
who are mindful of us at this time
and we ask that if you have the ability
to
to contribute some resources to
help that is great
but at this point
we do ask more that you respect the
privacy of the families involved and
that we will do our best as the
community leaders to give you
information through the media that would
allow you to have the information you
need to do your jobs and and allow that
privacy to be respected so
do you want to say anything if not we
can take a few questions
or Tim okay
my name is Tim Marriott I am the student
services coordinator
for the Iron County School District
um obviously this has had a tremendous
impact on our schools
we've got some amazing counselors and
therapists and social workers in our
schools that are doing a fantastic job
in the trenches as we speak
um we've mobilized our crisis uh mobile
response team in our schools and we've
definitely put in our therapists and
counselors at those schools that are
most impacted by this tragedy
um like the mayor said I've been blown
away at the resources that have been
offered to us we've had school districts
we've had County we've had private
clinicians that are all ready to jump in
drop everything that they're doing and
come support our students
and that support is just incredible and
that just speaks to the volume of the
the community that we live in
um we recognize that uh the the trials
and the the hard times are not going to
be done after today
um we notice that there's quite a few
students that are gone today in their
schools and we recognize that these next
several several days weeks months that
are coming are going to be difficult for
our schools and for our teachers
and I know that our our community and
our therapists and our school counselors
teachers they stand ready to be that
supporting that rock for these students
to make their day as normal as possible
with the difficult things that they will
continue to face so again I'm just so
grateful for our schools and for our
Administration and they are just really
doing a good job doing the best they can
even though that they are hurting
themselves but they're trying to put on
a brave face for our students
cute how many different schools
uh I like with the the age range I
believe there would be three schools
that were impacted uh is is it for so
there's there's an element to elementary
schools middle school and a high
schooler so
I'm one of the preschools Okay so we've
got four four different schools where
the students the children were attending
so
we don't have the law investigators are
still working on that that's the the
information that we had was that there
was a divorce petition filed uh that
investigation is still ongoing at this
point
uh it appears that it was according to
the court documents it was filed on the
21st of uh December and it was filed by
the wife so some detailed questions so
who's living in the house at the time
what is the husband or wife or who's
living in that house at this point we
don't have the details exactly of that
of the living situation we know that her
mother was there and had been there
providing support uh through the
difficulties that they were encountering
so
concern rates for a welfare check
uh at this point the individual who uh
who who made that welfare check request
given the investigation they were still
very early in the investigation uh we're
not a ready investigators would rather
not release that information at this
point
foreign
we don't have the official information
but there are witnesses who spoke with
members of the family the night before
they spoke the the daughter and the
mother were at a church activity the
night before
yes
in the neighborhood the the they're half
acre lots uh big big homes on half acre
lots uh you don't hear a lot coming from
your neighbor's homes so at this point
as I said we don't have any uh
information that we can release
regarding that but there's nothing that
uh I have had seen any corroborated
information on that would give us any
indication
[Music]
um
yeah we we had been involved in some
investigations with the family a couple
years prior
um at this moment I'd rather not
but but we were familiar with the family
yes was there anything recent or
anything that
since the divorce paper for trial with
their protected order or anything
nothing recent that law enforcement was
aware of no
we appreciate all of you coming
um you may have noticed that there's a
little quaking in our voices and a
little shininess to our eyes that's not
fear we're not afraid of you we all look
really friendly and nice people
this is what our public
feel
discussing it
talking to each other about it
brings out these emotions
and it's natural
the expectation is that we're supposed
to be tough
the police officers that investigated
that walked through
the home
that had to discover the information had
to record the information
they're human beings
they know this family
this is emotion that you see
so really what we're inviting the public
to do
through you the media and through our
friends and neighbors and all over the
world
is if you are a Praying person
to pray for law enforcement
it impacts them
pray for the family
if you're not a religious person
care for your family too
stand with your family
support them
love them
just like we love each other and we love
this family
we don't know why this happened
no one will probably know what was going
through
the minds of these individuals
however we do know
that they were our friends
they were our neighbors
and that we love them
so we appreciate you we appreciate the
time you've taken to be here we
appreciate everyone who is just lending
so much support
is that there was nothing that you could
do in this moment
I could ask the media that question
right
I could ask anybody that question and I
think it's that's a great question
there will be questions that everybody
asks themselves what if I had done this
what if I had done that those aren't
very good questions to ask
the question to ask is what do we do now
what do we do going forward
our police officers are tired
they're continuing to find out answers
they will continue
with very little rest the family members
the neighbors the friends
they continue forward
caring for talking about this
getting help if they are struggling with
it
resources are coming as as Mr Marriott
said they'll be here for them just reach
out and get help
don't hold it in do you know how long
the family had lived
you know what I think I I don't have the
answer to that question those questions
are ancillary and and it's appreciated
and those questions you can probably
find out in other resources so we're
going to end right now
aspect is the one
site we're we're not going to answer
more questions
you can make an amount you can probably
deduce some things from the press
release but we do thank you okay so
Community with the Las Vegas shooting uh
that's a good question we're going to go
ahead but you know this could go on
forever we're not going to we've got a
lot of things we have to do but I want
to answer that one last question okay
yes one of the victims of the Las Vegas
shooting was a resident here
and um
our hearts go out to maybe some
ancillary feelings that that family has
because this is not this is not a good
thing so thank you very much everyone
and you're free to to stick around and
and enjoy the room